news out of russia where russia is
continuing its military buildup along
the borders of ukraine and the russian
navy is also holding new exercises in
the region you see him there the u.s and
its european allies have given moscow a
written response to its demands for
security guarantees but has not granted
them and they are also preparing for a
possible russian invasion of ukraine
holly williams has more from the
ukrainian capital
there were more russian military drills
yesterday and six u.s fighter jets
arrived in eastern europe for nato
drills with roughly a hundred thousand
russian troops massed on ukraine's
border russia's demands include rolling
back nato forces from eastern europe and
a ban on ukraine joining nato america's
written response was hand-delivered
yesterday by the u.s ambassador to
moscow it hasn't been made public
but the u.s and nato have made it clear
they will not agree to those demands
the u.s reiterated an alternative
proposal it's made before the placement
effect of offensive missile systems
in ukraine military exercises and
maneuvers
in europe all of these things would
address i think mutual concerns
including concerns stated by russia
another concern is germany's dependency
on russia for its energy needs which
could fracture nato's solidarity
germany's the biggest buyer of russian
natural gas and has refused to send
weapons to ukraine
should russia choose to weaponize its
natural gas by cutting supply to europe
even more than it's already done
we're in discussions with governments
and major producers around the world
about surging their capacity
at st michael's golden domed monastery
in kiev
where the faithful have worshipped for
over 900 years
[Music]
some ukrainians told us they're praying
for peace
[Music]
this woman said she hopes god will talk
some sense into russia
the u.s says the ball is now in russia's
court but a kremlin spokesman said this
morning that russia's main concerns have
not been addressed by the u.s he also
said that the current situation is
reminiscent of the cold war gail
all right holly williams reporting from
ukraine thank you